good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight our capital city
washington
is under military occupation tonight by
inauguration day they're expected to be
more than 26
000 armed federal troops in washington
no
living american has seen a moment like
the one we're watching now
26 000 soldiers that's more than five
times the number of american military
personnel
currently stationed in iraq and
afghanistan combined
that is more than twice the number of
troops that president lyndon johnson
ordered to washington in april of 1968.
in april of 1968 washington dc was
literally
on fire race riots had broken out after
the assassination of martin luther king
whose memory we celebrate today more
than a thousand people were injured in
those riots and at least 13 of them died
much of the capital was leveled and it
stayed that way
blocks of charred rubble for decades if
you visited washington in the 1990s you
remember what it looked like
but according to our current leaders the
so-called insurrection of january 6th
was much worse than any of that so far
here is the death toll from that day
a police officer was hit in the head by
rioters then later had a stroke and died
at a local hospital
an unarmed protester was shot to death
by authorities as she tried to climb
through a window
a woman may have been trampled to death
by the crowd
as of tonight those are the three
casualties we can confirm from the riot
at the capitol building on january 6th
in response to that our leaders have
assembled the largest military presence
in washington
in all of american history during peace
time
in 1864 as the civil war raged on the
other side of the potomac
and americans died every day in large
numbers in battle
there were fewer federal troops
protecting washington dc
than there are tonight and it's truly a
national force
the guardsmen you see in washington have
come from every state in the union as
well as from puerto rico
and the question is why is that there's
no practical or
operational justification for it for
decades washington dc has had the
highest per capita law enforcement
presence in the country and one of the
highest in the world
so there was no need to fly in troops
from alaska to keep the city
safe but keeping the city safe was
hardly the point of the exercise
the murder rate in the district of
columbia has risen with terrifying speed
over the last six months
men women and children shot to death in
the streets
but no one in charge seems to care about
that or even notice their deaths
so no matter what they are telling you
those 26 000 federal troops are not
there for your safety
instead unmistakably the democratic
party is
using those troops to send the rest of
us a message about power
we're in charge now we run this nation
from honolulu to our colony in the
caribbean
and everything in between very much
including where you and your family live
do not question us men with guns enforce
our decrees
we control the pentagon and indeed they
do control the pentagon
republicans have spent years ignoring
the leftward drift of our officer corps
but we can't ignore it now the mask is
off our
military leadership the very same
generals who howled at the idea of
deploying american troops to stop an
invasion of our southern border
those same generals sent tens of
thousands of soldiers with rifles to
washington
purely as a show of force on behalf of
the political party they support
and once they did that they then allowed
democratic politicians to degrade and
politicize the military itself
democrats in congress demanded that the
troops sent to washington this week
submit to a political purity test
ideological
vetting as they put it to make certain
that every soldier professed loyalty to
the new regime
not loyalty to our country not loyalty
to our constitution
but loyalty to the aims of a specific
political party
nothing like that has ever happened in
america and just a few months ago it
would have been unimaginable
suddenly it's compulsory here's
congressman steve cohen of memphis
explaining why it is the guard
is 90 some odd percent i believe
male uh only about 20 percent of white
males voted for bible
you've got to figure that in the guard
which is predominantly more conservative
and i see that on my social media and we
know it
they're probably not more than 25 of the
people that are there protecting us who
voted for biden the other 75 percent
are in the class that would be uh the
large class of folks
who might want to do something
we should pause that tape and we should
consider for a moment
and think deeply about what congressman
steve cohen of tennessee just told us on
television
he said that every white man in this
country is a potential murderer every
white man in america should be under
suspicion
purely on the basis of being white and
male of planning
a presidential assassination he told us
the national guard is overwhelmingly
white and male therefore congressman
cohen says
white male national guardsmen must
undergo government background checks to
prove they're not planning murder
steve cohen didn't couch any of that he
just said it and the cnn anchor nodded
as he did
the rules on generalizations like this
have changed quite a bit in a very short
time
it wasn't that long ago it was november
5th 2009 that an army major called nadal
hassan opened fire on innocent people at
a military base in texas
the hassan shot 45 people at fort hood
13 of them died when it emerged later
that hassan was an islamic extremist
and then it emerged that the army had
failed to notice his extremism or in any
way protect the public
from his extremism no one at the
pentagon was court-martialed instead the
rest of us sat through months of
lectures about how we had no right
to come to broader conclusions about
what had happened at fort hood
yes the shootings were bad though not
barack obama made clear at the time
an act of terrorism but far worse than
mass murder we were told
would be the sin of drawing any
connection between anal hassan's beliefs
and the beliefs of anyone else in our
country nadal hassan was a single person
literally a lone gunman he was not a
stand-in for
all muslims so stop with your prejudice
rednecks
that's what they told us and by the way
it's okay that they told us that
most americans are decent people they
don't blame entire groups for the crimes
of a few
bigotry is immoral and so is collective
punishment
there is nothing more un-american than
that but not anymore
collective punishment is now the
official policy of the federal
government and it's enforced by the
pentagon
you'd love at some point to ask
congressman cohen about the implications
of this
since we've established this new
standard this new requirement of
collective punishment
what other groups of americans
congressman cohen should be denounced
and hurt
simply because of the way they look
simply because of the dna they were born
with
or does this new standard apply only to
white men and if it does apply
exclusively to white men which is
definitely the impression we're getting
from you
how does targeting white men contribute
to your stated goal of reducing
white male extremism because doesn't
attacking people
on the basis of qualities they can't
control make them more extreme
not less extreme aren't you persecuting
them
into behaving in precisely the ways you
claim you don't want them to behave
and since you're not a [ __ ] wouldn't
all of that be obvious to you
so why are you doing it why in the name
of fighting extremism are you
congressman cohen
creating extremism by the way dead
certain no question about it
that's exactly what you're doing
what steve cohen is your motive for
doing that
that's a sincere question by the way
congressman cohen is invited on this
show any time to give us his answer
in the meantime you've got to wonder
about what the guardsmen themselves
think of all of this this new policy
serving in the national guard is not
easy work guardsmen aren't paid much
some you've got to imagine are doing it
for love of country
now they've been deployed to their
country's own capital city and they've
been given orders to shoot their fellow
americans
if necessary that's a lot to ask now
suddenly on top of all of that they've
been told that if they were born a
certain way
if they're white and male and therefore
evil and dangerous
they themselves are under suspicion of
being the enemy
they're potential killers assassins
betrayers of a nation
we're not overstating this for a fact
here's a national guard commander in
puerto rico describing to his troops the
enemy they will face in washington
they are white nationalists he tells
them they are proud boys
if you wanted to stoke an irreparable
civil conflict you would talk this way
and you would keep talking that way
you'd tell armed men under your command
that they might have to shoot people who
voted for the wrong candidate in the
last election
you can see where this could all go it's
really scary
so where's the pushback from our
defenders well we didn't get any calls
today from republican senators begging
to come on this show to talk about any
of this or to push back against it
the democratic party is using the
military of the united states which they
do not own as a political weapon
but republicans in congress just can't
be noticed bothered to notice that
you think officers at the pentagon would
be outraged by this it's such a total
betrayal of everything our country and
the military are supposed
to stand for yet as far as we know
tonight not a single
officer has resigned in protest
background checks on people because of
their race and sex
because their political views why aren't
they protesting why aren't they
resigning
we can't say we know some clearly agree
with all of this and they'd like to see
it accelerate
quote i was chief prosecutor at
guantanamo for over two years a former
air force colonel
called moe davis announced on twitter
today and there's
far more evidence of congressman madison
cawthorne's guilt
than the guilt of more than 95 of the
detainees it is time we start a domestic
war on sedition by american terrorists
that's a verbatim quote and we'll repeat
that sentence in case you thought you
heard it incorrectly or we're making it
up we are not
a career american military officer has
now called for quote
a domestic war on sedition by american
terrorists a war
among those terrorists the ones he says
are literally more dangerous than al
qaeda and therefore must be imprisoned
and killed
is a 25 year old wheelchair-bound
madison cawthorne
who was just elected by american voters
to the united states congress
but according to colonel mo davis
congressman cawthorne and the millions
of americans who agree with him
the ones who voted republican in
november must be subdued by force
they are the enemy our military exists
to fight
now keep in mind that colonel davis
colonel mode davis
spent his life under arms so you can be
certain he isn't using the term
enemy in some metaphorical sense as in
oreos or the enemy of an effective diet
no
he means enemy in the way osama bin
laden and his co-conspirators of gitmo
were
our enemies and you remember what we did
to osama bin laden
has twitter seen mo davis's tweet has
the secret service
do they care does anyone will you know
the answer well a single one of colonel
mo davis's many allies in the democratic
party denounce what he said
or even tell him to cool it a little bit
and what about the news media
reporters are perpetually on the hunt
for what they describe as dangerous
extremism
have they noticed colonel mo davis on
twitter probably they have
but of course they agree with them just
today the daily beast the home page of
our highly credentialed but not super
bright ruling class
ran a piece with this title can u.s spy
agencies stop
white terror other countries the story
pointed out have domestic
spy agencies to fight extremists at home
so of course we need one right away
what the feast does not mention that
those other countries
would include china north korea
kazakhstan
domestic spy agency is a not very subtle
euphemism
for secret police that is what they're
calling for
now you'd think talk like that would
constitute a big red line for the many
professional freedom defenders in
washington the ones you send money to
the think tank libertarians for example
they're everywhere but not tonight where
are they tonight
a former u.s military officer declares
war on american citizens
members of the media call for a secret
police agency
this is the stuff of libertarian
nightmares
it's what they claim to hate so where
are they now
why isn't billionaire libertarian man of
principle charles koch spending billions
of dollars to stop
this these abridgements of liberty these
unprecedented attacks
on liberty he's definitely not spending
billions to stop it
doesn't seem doing anything no one is
and so it continues unabated democrats
in congress support a new secret police
agency but why wouldn't they support it
what better way to protect your own
power than funding a quote domestic spy
agency to fight extremists at home
those extremists needless to say will be
their political opponents
so you don't have to worry about them
anymore because they'll be in jail
just last year congressman brad
schneider of illinois sponsored
legislation to begin the process
of creating just such an agency
empowering
current agencies to spy on americans
based on their political beliefs
and guess what schneider's bill sailed
out of the house judiciary committee
all but two republicans voted for it nor
did republicans say a word when
congresswoman grace mang of new york
sponsored a bill to criminalize the
quote
purchase ownership or possession of body
armor
body armor not the ownership of guns or
bombs or even knives that's where you
thought we were
sheila jackson lee of texas just
introduced legislation to require a
license from the government in order to
own ammunition
well that seems nonsensical in extreme
especially from a party that released
thousands of violent criminals from
prison in just the last year
but no it's much crazier than that it's
banning
body armor devices that cannot under any
circumstances be used to hurt another
person
body armor is purely defensive body
armor exists only to protect the person
who is wearing
the body armor it is already a crime to
use body armor in most places while
committing a violent felony
this is different this would make it a
crime to possess body armor at all
why would you do that why would you make
it a crime to possess something designed
to save your life
that'd be like banning seat belts or
banning helmets
and actually now that we mention it
grace bang's bill would ban helmets
any helmet that might protect you from
gunfire
for real and honestly you should pause
when you hear that
what could possibly be the motive for it
we can't think of a non-sinister
explanation for banning body armor
it should make you nervous to hear it's
even being considered but again
republicans never said a word about this
they were too busy agreeing with
democrats that what happened at the
capitol
was a white supremacist insurrection
senator jim lankford oklahoma who tells
his voters he's conservative
just apologize to african-american
voters forever mentioning the
possibility of voter fraud since somehow
that is now racist how is that racist
exactly
we'll tell you exactly the truth what
happened on january 6th
was awful we don't like mobs we don't
like vandalism we don't like violence we
said it at the time we'll say it again
now we'll never stop saying it
but what happened on january 6 was not
an insurrection and there was nothing
racial about it that is a total lie it
is told and repeated purely for
political advantage
here's what it actually looked like
inside the capitol when the first
demonstrators burst in
hey man glad to see you guys you guys
patriots look at this guy he's got
covered in blood god bless you yes
you're good sir do you need medical
attention i'm good thank you all right
i got shot in the face
i got shot in the face with some kind of
plastic bullet any chance i could get
you guys to leave the senate wing
we will i've been making sure they ain't
disrespecting the place okay just want
to let you guys know this is like
the sacred place
just chatting with the cop on the house
floor the guy in the viking hat
chewbacca man you've seen him before is
a real life person
his name is jacob chansley chansley is
sitting in jail tonight he's being held
without bail bail was denied on friday
the judge who ordered him to rot in jail
presented no evidence that chansley was
violent or a threat to anyone
nevertheless the judge concluded quote
this is an insurrection
and jacob chansley was quote a symbol of
what occurred
he now faces 25 years or more in prison
if convicted you just saw the crime the
real crime though
was being a symbol of insurrection no
matter what happens jacob chansley will
almost certainly do more time in prison
than countless murderers rapists and
armed robbers actual criminals aren't a
problem for the democratic party in fact
they're an important constituency and it
shows
since memorial day about 90 percent of
the people arrested for gun crime in new
york city for example
have been released back onto the streets
free to do it again gun crime really
from the party that is against gun crime
right gun crime
gun violence yeah 90 released because
unlike jacob chansley they are not
symbols of insurrection and who else is
not a symbol of insurrection
these people
that was your country for months and
months on end
now they're pretending none of that ever
happened but it did happen
mobs have politicized thugs virtually
every one of whom supported the violent
overthrow of the elected president and
said so loudly at every opportunity
and spray painted on buildings went on
to torch and loot and vandalize major
american cities
in the city of minneapolis minnesota
alone b l
blm and antifa rioters burned or
destroyed more than 700 buildings
how many innocent people did they kill
we've counted more than
two dozen nationwide not including the
many hundreds murdered by criminals who
were sprung from lock-up in the name of
george floyd
we don't know the full death toll
probably never know nobody's keeping
track
there's no political advantage in
tallying the people that your side kills
but it's not a problem they tell us
because none of that was an insurrection
not even symbolically
so how long will this cycle go on if
you're hoping america will revert to
normal on wednesday afternoon after joe
biden is sworn in as president you are
an optimist
you probably assume the quarantines and
mandatory face coverings were temporary
too
probably not something awful has been
unleashed on our country
unchecked it will inevitably lead to
more awful things
every action provokes a reaction that is
physics it's also human nature
abraham lincoln understood this well in
january of 1838 lincoln spoke to an
audience in springfield illinois about
what happens when a society refuses to
punish
thugs and vandals it's not a small thing
citizens lincoln said
see their property destroyed their
families insulted and their lives
endangered their person's injured
and seeing nothing in prospect that
forebodes a change for the better
they become tired of and disgusted with
a government that offers them
no protection at that point lincoln
noted
they become radical they do things they
never would have considered if the
authorities had bothered to enforce the
laws they made in the first place
in other words they become liable to
show up at the capitol building in
viking hats and face paint
you could have scripted what was going
to happen on january 6th
what we can't know is what happens next
and let's pray that the people planning
a
war on american citizens find their
reason
and their decency and stop talking like
that immediately much less planning to
act on it
let's hope the biden campaign didn't
really mean it
when they promised to make quote the
same commitment to root out domestic
terrorism
as we have to stopping international
terrorism
think about that how would that project
end
you know the truth is we don't deserve
that
very few americans deserve to be treated
like osama bin laden
because they're not terrorists they
shouldn't be treated like isis
most americans are good people even if
you hate how they voted
we don't need a war within our borders
stop calling for one people in charge
only the worst people will win that war
huey long
understood this huey long was maybe the
only true economic populist ever elected
to the united states senate he was a
democrat back at a time when you could
be
an economic populist and still a
democrat and for that
he was more hated than donald trump ever
imagined he could be hated by
everyone not just republicans but by the
sitting democratic president franklin
roosevelt
hugh long was a very flawed guy they
always are
but he wasn't stupid in fact he had
flashes of wisdom
in 1935 huey long had a flash of wisdom
here's what he said
if the united states ever winds up with
a fascist government quote we will have
it under the guise
of anti-fascism that's right